bonjour à tous à suivre ce matin
l'audition de Bernard casazenu le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui a répondu
hier aux questions des sénateurs de la
commission des lois sur la lutte contre
le terrorisme les sénateurs avaient en
tête lors de leur questions à certain
nombre d'affaires récentes la faire
Mohamed Mera ou encore l'affaire mdine
mouche auteur de la tuerie du musée juif
de Bruxelles face à eux Bernard
casazneuve le ministre de l'Intérieur a
défendu sa stratégie en matière
d'anti-terrorisme et expliqué sa
stratégie il a notamment confirmé que de
nombreux terroristes ont commencé par la
délinquence ce qui soulève le problème
de la radicalisation en prison il a
également dénoncé le pouvoir des réseaux
sociaux et d'Internet capable je cite
d'une véritable manipulation secteur
tout de suite retour à cette audition
qui s'est déroulée hier après-midi au
Sénat monsieur le le ministre de
l'Intérieur Bernard
Caseneuve je tiens à vous remercier très
sincèrement au nom de tous mes collègues
d'une part de la commission des lois et
aussi de des sénateurs nombreux euh de
toutes les commissions qui ont bien
voulu nous rejoindre pour votre audition
euh celle-ci vous le voyez a suscité un
réel intérêt et cet intérêt il est lié
naturellement à l'actualité qui est la
nôtre nous avons tous en mémoire
l'horrible attentat quand on dit
horrible de toute façon tous les
attentats sont horribles mais l'attentat
antisémite de
Bruxelles que ce soit l'occasion pour
nous tous de dire notre solidarité euh à
toutes celles et tous ceux qui souffrent
de ce fléo qui est
l'antisémitisme toutes les formes de
racisme et nous savons monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur que vous êtes à
cet égard d'une grande vigilance vous
avez présenter une communication au
Conseil des ministres il y a plusieurs
semaines pour présenter des
disposition contre les sorts du
djihadisme dans notre pays et par
rapport à nos concitoyens qui sont
malheureusement
entraînés par ces mouvements nous
pensons naturellement aux jeunes et à
tous les
autres nous pensons aux victimes le
président de la République qui a
rappeler récemment qu'il y avait eu
30 français tués dans la période récente
en Syrie suite à leur entraînement dans
ces
mouvements nous vous voudrions vous
demander si vous vous voulez bien dans
un premier temps nous présenter le plan
que vous avez
conçu d'autre part vous le savez
Monsieur le Premier Ministre s'est
exprimé au Sénat jeudi
dernier suite à une
question à des questions que plusieurs
collègues et moi-même avion posé lors de
la science des questions
d'actualité et à indiquer qu'il
réfléchissait à un dispositif
législatif plus
resserré peut-être efficace qui
permettrait plus efficace qui
permettrait de
prévenir ces fléau et ces mouvements
toutefois nous sommes très attentif
naturellement à la nature de T
disposition parce qu'on voit très bien
qu'elles sont difficile à mettre en
œuvre et dans le cadre de notre système
de droit auquel nous tenons je j'arrête
ce propos introductif en disant que nous
tenons évidemment au respect de la vie
privée au respect des données
personnelles mais nous tenons tout
autant à ce qu'on lutte efficacement
contre le terrorisme et lutter
efficacement contre le terrorisme
suppose des mesures particulières qui
soient efficaces et qui F à protéger
notre société donc monsieur le le
ministre je vous propose de faire votre
exposé introductif si vous le voulez
bien puis nos collègues pourront ensuite
s'exprimer bien monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
tiens tout d'abord à vous remercier très
chaleureusement monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs pour votre invitation
à venir m'exprimer devant vous sur un
sujet qui est extrêmement grave
puisqu'il touche à la sécurité de notre
pays et de nos concitoyen le terrorisme
est une menace qui concerne absolument
tous les Français et dont chaque
responsable politique mesure
l'importance c'est pourquoi je vous suis
extrêmement reconnaissant de m'offrir
l'occasion d'apporter à tous les membres
de votre commission un éclairage que je
souhaite le plus complet possible sur la
politique que le gouvernement engagé
afin de lutter contre ce fléo et je me
réjouis monsieur le Président qu'il a
d'autres sénateurs que les sénateurs
membres de la commission des lois à
cette réunion la France comme d'autres
pays au sein de l'Union européenne est
en proie depuis plusieurs années à des
menace de filières terroristes des
individus qui sont fanatisés par un
discours religieux qui est dévoyés sont
décidés à frapper des innocents sur
notre
territoire exploitant l'actualité
internationale hier l'Algérie
aujourd'hui la Syrie des filières de
recrutement s'organise dans la
clandestinité
elles utilisent les réseaux de
communication pour diffuser un discours
de haine parfois déguiser d'ailleurs
sous des apparences humanitaires et
conduire des recrutes à entreprendre des
actions criminelles à l'étranger d'abord
puis à leur retour sur le sol
européen à cet égard je veux ici
récuser l'expression de loup solitaire
qui a fait floresse lors de l'attentat
commis par Mohamed Mera en mars 2012 à
Toulouse et qui a connu une seconde vie
pour qualifier Médin mouche après la
tuerie du musée juif de Bruxelles dont
vous avez parlé dans votre
introduction tout passage à l'acte aussi
individuel soit-il résulte d'un
cheminement et parfois ce cheminement
pas toujours mais parfois ce cheminement
vient de loin le processus de
radicalisation peut conduire à franchir
plusieurs étapes à se procurer des armes
à se rendre sur des zones de conflit où
le terrorisme peu à peu se répand le
passage à l'acte procède d'un
conditionnement psychologique qui pousse
celui qui se sent investi à accomplir
une mission
funeste ce que je veux dire c'est que
les complicités directes ou indirectes
sont déterminantes ne serait-ce que pour
en possession des armes utilisées par
les terroristes ce qui me conduit à
penser sans la moindre réserve que le
loup solitaire en est rarement
un il est l'instrument d'une violence
orchestrée à distance par des groupes
organisés et décidé à frapper et même
lorsque le contact avec la violence se
fait dans une relation exclusive de tout
autre avec Internet ce qui alimente ces
sites ces blogs ces forums font partie
euh d'organisations au sein desquelles
ils jouent un rôle et euh au sein
desquelles ils sont parfois en charge de
la diffusion d'une propagande qui se
trouve à l'origine du
basculement l'attentat perpétré au Musée
juif de Bruxelles le 24 mai dernier a
démontré d'ailleurs la terrible réalité
de cette menace le suspect que nous
avons arrêté à Marseille mdin mouche a
frappé sur le sol belge mais il était
lui-même de nationalité française comme
il était d'ailleurs l'une de ses
victimes comment mesurer l'importance de
cette menace je veux là donner quelques
chiffres que j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
donner au Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale
mais que je veux rappeler en les
actualisant au 30 mai dernier on compé
316 individus français ou résidant en
France qui combattaient en Syrie 139 en
partance pour ce pays 136 déjà de retour
en France ou en en Europe et 191 qui
manifestaient des validités de départ
nous devons donc traiter chacun de ces
cas comme constituant une menace
potentielle pour notre
sécurité le 23 avril dernier le Conseil
des ministre a donc adopté un plan de
lutte contre la radicalisation violente
et les filières terroristes plan de
lutte contre ces filières qui comportent
mesures toutes les mesures qui pouvaient
être prises à droit constant ont été
immédiatement mis en œuvre ell visent à
empêcher les départs notamment des
mineurs à démanteler les filières à
soutenir et orienter les familles
affligées par la radicalisation de l'un
de leurs
membres s'agissant de ce dernier point
un numéro d'appel national a été ouvert
dès le 29 avril et permet aux proches
des jeunes radicalisés ou en voie de
lettres de se signaler et d'obtenir de
l'aide et du conseil à ce jour la
plateforme a traité de 126 signalements
126 signalement uti les cas signalés ont
fait l'objet d'un accompagnement au plus
près des lieux de résidence par les
réseaux interservice mis en œuvre par
les préfets en étroite concertation avec
les procureurs de la République ces
signalements ont également permis
d'identifier 20 départ avérés pour
améliorer dispositif un programme de
formation a été proposé pour les
opérateurs de la plateforme et sera
développé dès le mois de juin à
l'attention des acteurs des réseaux de
soutien et d'orientation animés par les
préfets à l'échelon
local parallèlement l'action directe
contre les départs vers la Syrie a été
résolument
engagée trois procédures de retrait de
passeport français sont en cours une
expulsion de ressortissants étrangers a
été exécuté une autre est en
préparation la coopération entre les
services de l'État est piloté par les
préfets pour échanger des informations
permettant de recourir plus efficacement
aux décisions judiciaires d'interdiction
de sortie du territoire et aux mesures
administratif conservatoire d'opposition
à la sortie du territoire des mineurs
ces échanges facilitent la tâche des
parquets pour ordonner desplacements
provisoires lorsque la santé la sécurité
ou la mor des mineurs apparaît
compromise par un projet de
départ mais ne nous n'entendons pas nous
arrêter là nous devons poursuivre notre
travail de lutte contre la diffusion de
l'idéologie qui encourage ces jeunes à
partir la radicalisation à laquelle nous
assistons en milieu carcéral notamment
constitue à ce titre un sujet
d'inquiétude majeure c'est pourquoi nous
sommes en train de travailler avec
madame la garde des saau à une série de
mesures permett an de renforcer l'action
des services de renseignement
pénitentiaire d'améliorer le statut des
homoniers pénitentiaires et de prendre
en charge les individus radicalisés au
terme de leur détention d'autres mesures
que nous nous proposons de prendre
présentent un caractère législatif c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement prépare un
projet de loi dont le Parlement sera
saisi à l'aéé et qui devrait notamment
comporter les points suivants sur
lequels je vais vous donner toutes les
informations premier point interdiction
du départ à l'étranger de ressortissant
français majeurs lié à des activités
terroristes ce qui est actuellement
impossible en dehors d'une mesure de
contrôle
judiciaire généralisation de l'enquête
sous pseudonyme sur internet à
l'ensemble des activités à caractère
terroriste le gouvernement envisage dans
le même temps l'introduction d'une
nouvelle
incrimination commise par un individu
qui après avoir connu un long
cheminement après avoir été conditionné
radicalisé en un mot préparé aurait
décidé de passer à l'acte et
d'entreprendre une action à caractère
terroriste elle s'ajouterait à
l'association de malfaiteurs en bande
organisée en relation avec une
entreprise terroriste qui est une
incrimination pénale qui qui s'adresse
davantage au réseau terroristes qu'aux
individus radicalisés manipulés dans le
but de commettre les pires
extrémités cette nouvelle incrimination
pénale est le résultat d'entretien que
j'ai pu avoir avec un certain nombre
d'entre vous mais aussi avec des juges
antiterroristes qui se sont exprimés par
le truchement de tribune dans lesqueles
ils nous ont fait part de leur souhait
de voir à juste titre la législation
évoluer d'autre part les sites internet
faisant l'apologie du terrorisme
mériteraient d'être traité selon un
régime identique à celui des site
internet faisant l'apologie des crimes
contre l'humanité incitant à la haine
raciale
ou diffusant des contenus à caractère
pédopornographique enfin je souhaite
souligner qu'une lutte efficace contre
ces menaces passe nécessairement par une
coopération renforcée avec nos
partenaires de l'Union
européenne sur le sujet de la lutte
contre le terrorisme c'est par le
renforcement de la coopération avec les
pays de l'Union européenne au sein de
l'espace Schengen à travers le
signalement au fichier des personnes
recherchées au système d'information
Schengen à travers une relation plus
étroite une coopération plus étroite
entre les services de renseignement dès
lors que ce signalement a été effectué
que réside la solution au problèmes
auxquels nous sommes confrontés le
renforcement de la coopération
européenne et donc sur le sujet qui nous
intéresse la solution l'Europe n'est en
aucun cas le
problème la semaine dernière j'ai donc
pris part à Luxembourg à la 5e rencontre
des ministres de l'Intérieur réunissant
les Européens dont les pays son sont le
plus touchés par le terrorisme
djihadiste ce cette réunion avait été
invité par Joë milket ma collègue belge
et par moi-même et nous allons
poursuivre ce travail intense
d'approfondissement de nos contacts avec
l'ensemble des pays de l'Union
européenne pour faire en sorte que cette
coopération donne des résultats à
l'occasion de la réunion du Luxembourg
j'ai proposé à mon homologue Joë milket
une série de mesures que nous avions
préparé ensemble et qui ont été
largement soutenu par les autres membres
participants celle-ci porte sur
l'élaboration de pratique commune pour
l'utilisation des données sur les
passagers des lignes aériennes
dispositif d' PNR pour les signalements
au système d'information Schengen pour
les contrôles aux
frontières extérieures de l'Union
européenne y compris pour les
ressortissants européens et pour
l'information et le suivi lorsque une
personne rentre de Syrie et est détecté
sur le territoire de l'Union
européenne par ailleurs sur la base
d'une proposition du Royaume Unis une
Task force européenne sera chargée
d'aider les États-membres à
l'élaboration d'un contred-iscours en
réponse à ceux qui peuvent être diffusés
par les sites djihadistes enfin nous
avons prévu de rencontrer dans le
courant de ce mois et à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne et ensemble au sein
de l'Union européenne les principaux
opérateurs de l'Internet afin de définir
les possibilités de retrait immédiat des
sites de messages diffusant la haine de
l'autre ou qui encourage au crime et au
terrorisme un dernier point doit être
également mentionné la menace syrienne
ne doit pas nous faire baisser la garde
sur les autres fronts encore
ouverts la zone du sel doit rester
l'objet d'une attention très
vigilante j'ai eu l'occasion de
participer à la fin du mois de mai en
Mauritanie à une rencontre avec mes
homologues de Mauritanie du Tchad du
Mali du burgina Faso du Niger mais
également du Sénégal afin d'apporter
notre soutien dans les décisions qu'ils
peuvent prendre pour lutter au niveau
régional contre le terrorisme qui trouve
le terrorisme dans l'immensité de ces
régions la possibilité de prospérer en
tirant profit on le sait du trafic
d'armes du trafic parfois de éfiant mais
aussi de l'exploitation des migrants
clandestins monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs le 4
juin
dernier je me suis rendu au Musée juif
de Bruxelles pour porter aux familles
deuillé et aux communautés juif de
Belgique et de France un message de
soutien et de
compassion ce message je ne l'ai pas
exprimé au nom du gouvernement mais au
nom de nous tous à chaque fois que notre
pays a été exposé par le passé à une
menace terroriste particulièrement aigu
il s'est montré toujours solidaire il
s'est montré toujours
résolu le gouvernement n'épargnera aucun
effort pour protéger nos concitoyens
contre cette menace je sais que nous
pouvons compter sur votre soutien pour
nous aider à remplir cette mission dans
un esprit de concorde républicaine c'est
un travail que nous devons et que nous
pouvons mener ensemble c'est un travail
qui doit nous conduire à œuvrer de
concert toutes les idées et suggestions
pouvant venir en appui du plan qui a été
présenté en Conseil des ministres et qui
doit trouver une transcription
législative au Parlement dans les
prochaines semaines j'ai pu la semaine
dernière devant la commission des lois
de l'Assemblée
nationale apporter un soutien à une
proposition de loi émanant de
parlementaire d'un parlementaire de
l'opposition qui faisait des des
propositions tout à fait utiles qui ont
été soutenu et pour partie intégré dans
le plan qui sera proposé à la
délibération du Parlement prochainement
je crois que cet esprit
d'unité de solidarité dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme et la condition de
la réussite de ce que nous entreprenons
ensemble pour éviter que nos
ressortissant et notre pays ne soit
exposé à des risques graves de sécurité
voilà monsieur monsieur le Président ce
que je voulais dire de façon synthétique
sur notre sujet du jour et bien entendu
je suis tout à fait disposé à répondre à
toutes les questions que les sénateurs
et sénatrices voudront bien me poser
merci Monsieur le le ministre de
l'Intérieur je vous je note que vous
avez bien voulu pour la première fois
donner connaissance au Sénat des quatre
pistes auxqueles le gouvernement
travaille en en ce qui concerne un
nouveau dispositif pénal relatif au
terrorisme interdiction de sortie du
territoire enquête sous
pseudonyme complément à l'association de
malfaiteurs sous la forme d'une
incrimination qui permettrait si j'ai
bien compris de toucher des personnes
dont il serait avéré fusent-elle isolée
qu'elle prépare un acte terroriste
enfin les questions de l'apologie du
terrorisme en particulier sur les sites
internet je crois que c'est important
d'avoir informé en premierf en priorité
le Sénat de ces pistes de travail qui
demanderont naturellement à vous comme à
nous beaucoup
d'attention mes chers collègues je vais
vous donner bien sûr la parole alors
j'ai comme
inscrit Monsieur le Comte monsieur
monsur
Colomba Monsieur laasser Madame Benbassa
monsieur Vial Monsieur Michel
oui monsieur
cointa monsieur
frasa bien madame
garuméam bien alors cela fait 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8
9 neu intervenants puis on verra si
d'autres se révèlent en cours de route
donc Monsieur le
Comte je vous remercie monsieur le le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je voudrais peut-être avant de
poser quelques questions et faire part
de quelques questionnements que j'ai sur
cette problématique faire un petit
préalable d'abord pour dire que les les
victimes des derniers attentats on tous
étai des personnes de confession juivees
que les attentats à Toulouse ou à
Bruxelles le sont et que ça témoigne si
une part de notre communauté nationale
parce que la conséquence de ça c'est que
une part importante et j'ai pu me rendre
compte dans un déplacement en Israël
récemment du nombre de jeunes français
arrivant en Israël qu'une part
importante de notre communauté nationale
ne voit plus son avenir dans notre
pays de notre côté je constate que une
société qui exclut une société qui
stigmatise une religion provoque aussi
des violences et que il y a aussi
d'autres membres de la même communauté
nationale qui aujourd'hui et vous avez
signé cité des chiffres dériv de plus en
plus en s'engageant violemment contre
notre communauté nationale en la mettant
en danger donc dans les deux cas il y a
un problème de cohésion de l'ensemble de
notre communauté qui a besoin d'un
projet qui mobilise toute sa diversité
et toutes ses composantes et que ce
n'est c'est d'abord par cette volonté de
de tenir la société en cohésion avec un
projet commun que nous pourrons lutter
contre les dérives
d'aujourd'hui que par conséquent la
sensibilisation à à cette problématique
est sans doute le premier intérêt du
débat que nous avons aujourd'hui mais je
voudrais aussi
ajouter que concernant la situation des
djihadistes en
Syrie il ne faut
pas mesur penser que ce qui a pu être
dit depuis 1 an un an et demi sans
mesure et sans limite sur la situation
dramatique humanitairement en Syrie ne
peut pas provoquer chez des jeunes un
intérêt et il faut le dire et par
conséquent je crois qu'il y a besoin de
ce point de vue-là d'éviter de faire
d'une destination euh un délit euh il y
a eu euh un certain nombre de choses qui
ont été constaté et dit sur la situation
humanitaire en Syrie depuis 1 an euh il
est bien évident que euh cela interpelle
les plus jeunes euh certains plus jeunes
qui peuvent se sentir en même temps euh
exclus de la société alors euh une fois
que j'ai dit ça de manière peut-être un
peu brutale je voudrais euh d'abord dire
que il est jamais
bon de d'écrire une loi à un moment où
l'émotion retenti encore qu'on a déjà un
arsenal législatif existant par
conséquent quand moi je lis par exemple
dans une communication que le
Parlement sera saisi d'un projet
organisant un régime d'opposition à la
sortie du territoire de personnes
majeures engagées dans des activités
terroristes je me dis si elles sont
engagées dans des activités terroristes
elles devraient déjà tomber sur le coup
de la loi
euh et et et tout ça me fait dire qu'il
faut essayer de d'avancer sur cette
problématique avec la la la la la
volonté de ne pas légiférer trop
vite sans en mesurer toutes les les
conséquences on a vu par le passé à
chaque fois qu'on qu'on légiférait dans
l'émotion il y avait toujours un certain
nombre d'effets pervers qu'on constatait
derrière après il y a la question d'
internet alors bien entendu les délit
sur Internet doivent être poursuivis euh
à la fois le délit et puis ce qu'on
observe quand ce qu'on observe doit être
qualifié de de délit toutefois ces
protections et et la loi sera jamais
supérieure à la technique et à ses
capacités il faut donc mesurer à quel
point ces dispositions seront finalement
limitées et que leur premier le premier
intérêt des débats qu'on peut avoir sur
le sujet c'est là encore de la de la
sensibilisation
par contre il y a une proposition que
j'aimerais faire parce que quand on
entend le besoin de suivre les
mouvements nous avons un espace Schengen
que certains attaquent et considèrent
comme un un élément alors que il
faudrait le considérer comme un espace
de liberté de circulation comme un
espace qui justement parce qu'il est
grand permet des circulations et
mériterait aujourd'hui d'être
détricoté je crois au contraire qu'il
faudrait qu'il soit plus protégé et que
par conséquent l'une des propositions
qui me semblerait aller dans le sens du
suivi des mouvements de qui sont
nécessaires pour lutter contre le
terrorisme c'est que comme un certain
nombre de grands pays de grandes
démocrati l'ensemble des entrées et
sorties de l'espace Schengen fasse
l'objet d'un suivi biométrique pour les
entrées et pour les sorties de manière à
être capable de savoir qui rentre et qui
sort de cet espace de liberté c'est une
démarche qu'on doit faire avec nos
partenaire Schengen mais il me semble
que ce serait la meilleure démarche à ce
que nous recherchons aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire la sécurisation de
l'ensemble de cet espace de liberté et
qui doit rester un espace de
sécurité merci Monsieur le Comte
monsieur
Colomba monsieur le ministre personne
ici je crois ne doute de la volonté du
du gouvernement de de faire face à ce à
ce fléo et ce que vous nous avez dit
comme proposition bon sous bénéfice de
l'examen qu'on en aura sur les
implications et cetera a priori ne ne me
choque pas particulièrement enfin je
suis surpris non pas pas la première
fois mais enfin le terrorisme c'est pas
une nouveauté en France ça fait
plusieurs dizaines d'années on sent et
je veux bien admettre que il prend des
formes enfin il y a des mutations c'est
pas c'est pas toujours les mêmes formes
hein au début ça a été plutôt orchestré
par des pays étrangers ça allit un peu
moins maintenant enfin et cetera mais
je pense quand même que le moment est
venu d'essayer d'aborder le problème de
façon globale parce que le terrorisme
c'est pas seulement un problème de
police et de renseignement même si on a
réformé il y a pas si longtemps que ça
les le le le le renseignement c'est
c'est devenu un problème de société
quelque part je rejoins mon mon mon mon
collègue est-ce qu'il serait pas temps
bon je veux bien qu'on prenne des
mesures de de circonstances parce que
bon très bien je veux bien le comprendre
mais est-ce qu'il serait pas temps de
poser le problème globalement et et
justement d'en voir toutes ces
dimensions vous avez abordé par exemple
le rapport
entre la prison et puis le développement
du terrorisme on va voter une loi on en
examen dans quelques temps à ma
connaissance ce problème n'est pas n'est
pas abordé je veux dire que est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas quand on on fait une loi
pénale intégrer ce type de de dimension
de même parce que disait mon collègue
tout à l'heure le statut la place les
difficultés de la religion musulmane et
et de et C corén en France ça mériterait
peut-être d'être d'être approfondi et et
pour de façon à ce qu'on essaie
d'apporter une réponse globale à ce
problème qui est un problème global qui
est tout autant un problème
d'éducation de de de communication
d'intégration et cetera qu'un problème
de police même si et de reassinement
même si cette dimension là évidemment ne
doit pas être
sous-estimé merci Monsieur Colomba
monsieur
lasser je voudrais monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous remercier très
sincèrement parce que ces débats sont
des débats quand même de privilégié au
niveau de l'information que l'on reçoit
et des échanges que l'on peut avoir
euh je suis complètement d'accord l
ceque vous dites monsieur le ministre
qu'il y a différentes forme de
terrorisme et chacun d'entre nous bien
entendu est sensible à celle qu'il pense
côtoyer dont il pense être le plus près
je voudrais vous parler une seconde je
parle sous le contrôle de Monsieur
Morvan qui est qui a SZ vie en Pays-Bas
qui pour notre bonheur d'ailleurs
euh je voudrais vous parler du du du
terrorisme du terrorisme basque et vous
dire et alors
c'est une recherche d'information une
suggestion je ne sais pas comment
puis-je le formuler euh nous avons
l'impression alors c'est une forme très
particulière les causes sont
complètement différentes les techniques
d'alimentation sont identiques
vous avez je crois tout à fait raison
dans votre analyse on assiste je le
crois en tout cas la majorité des
acteurs considèrre que la volonté de le
TA de déposer les armes n'est pas dénué
complètement de sincérité nous sommes
certains à consacré à constater ou à
considérer que
c'est une proposition qu'il ne faut pas
prendre à la légère et que et qui de
notre point de vue c'est pas le point de
vue exclusif mais le point de vue très
important en Paysbasque nous considérons
que des propositions comme
cellees-ci doivent comment dirais-je
doivent être accompagné de d'une
attention particulière de ceux qui
dirigent notre pays où qu'il soit par
rapport au processus de paix hein et il
y a une réelle interrogation je le crois
et un réel une réelle envie de rentrer
et ma question c'est faut-il négocier
jusqu'où peut-on négocier les
négociations ont-elles je le crois des
caractères complètement différents mais
sur la forme de terrorisme que
j'évoque je je puis vous dire que nous
sommes très nombre à considérer que nous
aurions tout à gagner à condition de
sarquebouter sur des principes
républicains que nous défendons nous
aurions tout à gagner à à écouter et à
parler alors je sais que la question est
très délicate notamment à votre niveau
et tous les gouvernements successif ont
été embarrassés par cette question mais
en tout cas lorsqu'il y a des évolutions
notamment chez la jeunesse des
évolutions constatées d'abandon de la
lutte armé pour en arriver à des pistes
un peu plus comment dirais-je un peu
plus Humes ou je crois que nous devrions
regarder
voilà merci Monsieur laasser Madame
Benbassa merci monsieur le ministre
pour pour votre intervention qui ne
pourrait être d'accord avec vos vos
mesures mais toutefois comme je l'avais
déjà dit lors de ma question au
gouvernement jeudi qui s'adressait à
vous mais vous étiez à
l'étranger je ne sais pas si ces mesures
seront
euh tout à fait efficaces vu que aussi
bien Mera que l'actuel terroriste
euh sont des gens qui étaient connus par
les services secrets et contre qui on n
rien fait deuxièmement euh parce qu'on
peut multiplier les mesures et ne pas
les attraper ces personnes peuvent
commettre leurs crimes et continuer à le
faire euh d'abord comme vous le savez et
vous l'avez dit monsieur le président
l'a dit aussi aujourd'hui
l'antisémitisme est de nouveau sur une
pente meurtrière et avec l'histoire que
l'Europe a connu euh elle ne peut pas se
permettre la France et compris la
France ne peut pas se permettre de
laisser faire et c'est un devoir de tous
les démocrates de combattre aussi bien
l'antisémitisme que toute forme de
racisme cela dit euh est-ce que euh
comme mes camarades l'ont dit et que je
l'avais également écrit dans ma ma
question euh est-ce que ce n'est pas un
problème global mais je ne sais pas je
ne connais pas dans l'histoire de France
des des étudiants sortis de Science Po
devenus euh euh terroristes il y a quand
même un vrai problème de fond qu'on ne
veut pas voir les mesures policières
sont sont très bien les mesures
punitives sont très bien mais euh
prenons en compte qu'il y a un problème
qui concerne une partie de notre
jeunesse et qui a été oubliée et le
djihad n'est qu'une des
manifestation désespoir euh chaque
groupe répond à à son désespoir d'une
autre façon les uns votent extrême
droite les autres deviennent diihadistes
même si on ne peut pas comparer euh les
toutes ces attitudes euh néanmoins
euh il faut prendre aussi en
considération qu'il y a euh dans le dans
le djihadisme une un problè un véritable
problème euh parce que euh on ne on
prend tous les risques sachant qu'on va
mourir alors aucune loi ne pourrait
prévenir cela euh puisque je sais pas
prenez le cas de
Mera il savait qu'il allait être tu il a
continué jusqu'au dernier moment cette
personne qui a été attrapée aussi enfin
le présumé coupable et du de l'acte
terroriste du musée juif de Bruxelles a
pris quand même un bus qui est souvent
contrôlé parce que il y a des Diler qui
prennent ce ce bus donc ces gens-là ont
pris quand même le risque de mourir et
contre ce cette volonté de devenir
Shahid martyre personne ne peut rien euh
mais est-ce que ce serait pas préférable
de de de prendre des mesures beaucoup
plus
sociétales autour euh de ces de ces
jeunes
désespéré que de multiplier les mesures
comme je l'ai déjà dit deuxièmement il
ne faudrait pas que ces mesures lié à un
fait divers comme l'a dit Monsieur le
conte ne se repè percute pas sur ces
paisibles
musulmans de notre communauté française
qui ce qui bien sûr subiront les
retombées et au sein de la population
qui va les stigmatiser encore davantage
voilà excusez-moi d'avoir été
longue merci Madame
Benbassa monsieur Vial
oui monsieur le ministre comme beaucoup
d'entre nous ici j'ai été sensible aux
mesures qui ont été annoncées
récemment président du groupe France
Syrie je me trouvais avec quelques-uns
d'ailleurs de cette assemblée au camp de
réfugiés de Gaziantep il y a quelques
mois et nous avons effectivement été
frappé lors de nos rencontres avec les
ONG notamment les médecins Médecins du
Monde de nous dire la violence que
représentait pour eux et le risque que
représentait pour eux euh judaï judaï
qui qui était là et qui les menaçait
alors que certains étaient de la
banlieue parisienne et un médecin
d'ailleurs qui qui nous disait avoir
échappé au pire parce que par chance un
médecin qui se trouvait exactement dans
le département de ce jeune les avait
rejoints et a pu discuter pour essayer
de de de de le calmer sur ses intentions
simplement parce que aidant des
populations diverses des variés il
s'agissait pour eux bien évidemment
d'aider tous ceux qui se présentaient
quel que soit leur origine ils étaient
donc suspects et donc de devait mourir
donc je je donne cet exemple parce
qu'effectivement on voit que on est bien
l'au-delà bien évidemment on peut avoir
des lecture à l'égard de de quelques
communautés l'antisémitisme bien
évidemment ne peut pas être écarté mais
on voit bien qu'on est dans un
radicalisme religieux qui est un
radicalisme religieux qui pose un vrai
problème qui est une situation grave et
donc vous vous évoquez bien évidemment
parmi les différentes mesures celles qui
qui concerne la protection et la
sécurité qui doit être donée sur les
sites internet d'apologie parce que de
toute évidence c'est un un environnement
et des sources qui sont loin d'être
négligebles mais on voit bien
aujourd'hui qu'on est dans un
environnement beaucoup plus large vous
avez parlé de l'Europe j'étais cette fin
de semaine avec des des gens du Burkina
Faso des élus de cette région qui
parlent effectivement de la crâne qu'ils
ont euh et qui disait très clairement
concernant le Mali le jour où l'armée
française quittera le Mali euh ne nous
faisons aucune illusion sur ce qui va se
passer parce que donc ça montre bien
qu'effectivement nous sommes dans dans
ces régions dans des réservoir si vous
me permettez l'expression où ces
populations trouve refuge ce qui montre
bien que si nous n'avons pas une
politique globale et là pour le coup
nous sommes plus sur le coup du du
ministère de la Défense que celui de
l'intérieur ça nécessite effectivement
des des des relations très étroites
entre ces pays vous les avez déilleurs
cité entre la défense et l'intérieur
entre l'Europe mais qui est de toute
évidence une politique de fond car je
crois très sincèrement vous nous avez
donné tout à l'heure des
chiffres l'unité dans laquelle vous vous
êtes rentré nous a quelque peu étonné en
tout cas m'a étonné et notamment la la
la la Modesti des chiffres c'est quand
on est sur le chiffre sur le terrain
alors vous me direz que ce sont toutes
des données qui sont approximatives
mais les chiffres qu'on nous donne quand
on est sur le terrain seraient plutôt
des unités
supérieures aux chiffres que vous avez
donné enfin peu importe on est pas là
pour pour épiloguer sur sur les unités
ce qui montre quand même que nous sommes
sur une situation particulièrement grave
et que on sans vouloir ramener le
conflit syrien à cette situation nous
savons que le conflit syrien a de toute
évidence pris une toute autre nature
notamment dans certaines régions à
partir du momentù où ces radicaux se
sont infiltrés et ont les les actions
que l'on connaisse donc effectivement
monsieur le ministre c'était sur ces
liens avec le ministère de la Défense
savoir comment les choses sont mises en
place parce que de toute évidence ce ne
sont pas uniquement des mesures pénales
circonscrite à not territoirees qui
pourront enrayer ce phénomène beaucoup
plus
large monsieur Vial Monsieur
Michel merci Monsieur le Ministre bien
entendu on peut être que d'accord sur
le l'effort global du gouvernement pour
combattre ce terrorisme mais je poser
une question juridique sur le la
première incrimination que vous prévoyez
qui est l'interdiction de sortie du
territoire comment peut-on interdire
sortir du territoire à des Français
majeur qui n'ont commis sur le
territoire aucune
infraction si cela était rétroactif
aurait-il fallu incriminer les Français
qui sont allés des des républicains
espagnols ou ceux qui sont all rejoind
des terroristes à Londres qui était
condamné à
mort merci
Monsieur Michel euh monsieur Quinta
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre vous nous avez présenté tout
un programme législatif pour améliorer
le dispositif de lutte contre le
terrorisme très bien bon je ne rentre
pas dans les détails de N de notre
collègue mais effectivement je me posais
un peu la même question sur la sortie du
territoire vous avez également pris des
contact avec vos homologues de l'Union
européenne et c'est parfait parce qu'il
faut effectivement lutter ensemble on ne
peut pas le faire seul mais il y a quand
même un problème qui se pose et
j'aimerais bien que vous nous en parliez
c'est qu'en fait on est en train d'agir
sur les
effets mais on laisse toujours de côté
les
causes voyez moi ce qui me préoccupe
c'est que on ne peut pas arriver à
modifier le cerveau d'un jeune en le
lavant d'une manière telle qu'il va
vouloir préférer la mort à la vie qu'il
va préférer la haine à l'amour en 5
minutes c'est un travail
considérable qui met en jeu évidemment
la spiritualité donc la religion et il
faut des spécialistes pour se faire et
des spécialistes qui ont une certaine
aura sinon il ne seraient pas entendu
par ces jeunes donc moi je suis très
préoccupé par cela car ce n'est pas à
l'extérieur de nos frontières que ça se
passe c'est pour la plupart d'entre eux
à l'intérieur de nos frontières donc que
peut-on faire qu'envisagez-vous de faire
et je sais que vous faites déjà beaucoup
comme vos prédécesseurs d'ailleurs mais
ce n'est pas suffisant pour arriver à
éliminer ces lavages de cerveau
abominaablees mais mais il y a aussi une
deuxième élément quand on est dans une
religion et nous avons connu chaque
religion a connu ses heures noires comme
par exemple la chrétienté avec et et le
catholicisme à avec l'Inquisition mais
là aussi on savait très bien que la
seule façon de s'en sortir c'est parce
que finalement c'est l'Église
elle-même qui a éradiqué si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi les éléments les plus
perturbateurs en son
seint donc on arrive un peu à une
situation semblable comment faites-vous
puisque vous êtes aussi le ministre des
Cultes pour qu'à ce niveau on puisse
essayer de responsabiliser davantage
l'églises entre guillemets c'est-à-dire
les religieux musulmans qui sont au
premierers chefs concernés et qui sont
souvent les premières
victimes deuxièmement est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas qu'il y a aussi un moyen de
d'agir par ce biais pour qu' il y ait un
autre message qui soit plutôt celui de
l'entend de l'amour de de la bonne
relation entre les uns et les autres
comme le font en général les religions
je me suis permis de lire un peu le
Coran j'ai pas tout compris mais c'est
quand même plutôt un message d'amour que
de haine et quand je dis plutôt c'est
même tout à fait tout à fait donc il y a
il y a quand même des armes extrêmement
utiles parce que ce sont celles de la
sagesse qui peuvent jouer alors que
faites-vous dans ce à ce niveau-là enfin
car je veux pas être trop long puisque
il y a d'autres orateurs je voudrais
quand même là aussi que on comprenne que
euh la véritable le véritable coupable
et peut-être moins le jeune qui
totalement endoctriné va commettre des
crimes que celui qui a armé son bras et
qui l'a mis en dans de telles conditions
et là que faites-vous pour être
impitoyable de telle façon que l'on
sache que il n'y aura pas d'impunité à
ce niveau-là voilà Monsieur le Ministre
quelques questions il y en a d'autres
mais déjà je pense que ça suffit pour ce
soir merci merci Monsieur cointam
monsieur Frassa merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre j'ai une
toute petite question parce que comme
vous l'avez vu une actualité chassant
toujours l'autre on est sans nouvelle si
je puis dire de la sœur Mera depuis
l'affaire du musée juif de Bruxelles
donc on ne sait toujours pas si elle est
en Tunisie ou si elle est réellement en
Syrie puisqu'on a depuis que que c cette
sinistre affaire de du de des assinat du
musée juif on on a les nouvelles les
informations n'existent plus si je puis
dire sur euh la fuite de la de la sœur
Mera du territoire français donc ça
c'est ma première question donc si vous
avez des éléments à nous donner je
serais je serais intéressé de les
entendre euh ma deuxème question c'est
pour rebondir sur ce que disait notre
collègue Michel sur l'interdiction de
sortie du territoire il y a aussi un
autre aspect il y a aussi de nombreux
binationaux
et là aussi on peut interdire à un
ressortissant français l'interdiction de
sortie du territoire mais il y a aussi
les binationaux qui peuvent sortir avec
les leurs papi d'identité de leur autre
nationalité donc là-dessus comment aussi
peut-on peut-on aussi
euh être efficace par de telles mesures
et
pour une autre question c'est ce que
l'on entend très souvent c'est la
radicalisation ça se fait en prison nous
diton et comment peut-on
intervenir je sais que ça n'est pas de
votre ressort puisque c'est plutôt
l'administration pénitentiaire mais
c'est peut-être aussi de votre ressort
puisque on entend la plupart du temps
les imames je
dire dire déclarer leur impuissance dire
on n pu rien faire on ne peut rien faire
on constate euh il y a cette
radicalisation rampante mais certaine
efficace comment peut-on associer
euh soit via le conseil du culte
musulman soit par les imams qui
interviennent dans les dans les dans les
en milieu carcéral rendre
efficace je dirais pour employer un
terme médical le dépistage
euh précoce
de potentielle radicalisation ou en tout
cas d'éléments qui peuvent être à
l'origine de radicalisation et
juguler dans le milieu carcéral cet
endoctrinement de de jeunes gens qui
comme c'était le cas semble-t-il
pour le le présumé tueur enfin le
présumé assassin du musée juif qui
semble-t-il à l'origine n'était en rien
un fanatique islamiste qui le serait
devenu par ses séjours en
prison et
enfin et enfin je ne me relis
pas ah oui et enfin oui quit de euh des
pays que je dirais entre guillemets amis
qui financent le terrorisme quel
situation prendre vis-à-vis d'eux euh
quelle attitude avoir vis-à-vis d'eux et
quelle surtout quelle peut-être
finalement sanction avoir vis-à-vis
d'eux parce que on ils sont
officiellement nos amis mais on sait
pertinemment ce qu'ils font pour
financer le terrorisme donc y y a-t-il
des mesures à prendre il y a-t-il une
position à avoir vis-à-vis d'eux il y
a-t-il une politique à changer vis-à-vis
d'eux
P merci Monsieur Frassa madame
garumam ouici merci monsieur le
Président permettez-moi tout d'abord de
vous remercier d'avoir ouvert cette
session à d'autres sénateurs et j'y suis
d'autant plus sensible que représentant
le Sénat l'Assemblée parlementaire de
l'OTAN j'ai été chargé par cette
assemblée parlementaire de rédiger un
rapport sur le terrorisme et sur les
moyens de travailler en commun pour
essayer d'éradiquer ou de limiter ce
phénomène merci pour tout ce que vous
nous avez dit monsieur le ministre mais
je crois vraiment vous entendant en
écoutant ce qui été dit par mes
collègues que je partage en très grande
partie que nous devons vraiment vraiment
travailler au niveau interministériel je
crois que ça doit être une vraie
politique globale parce que nous avons
besoin de développer la prévention et ce
n'est pas uniquement au niveau du
ministère de l'Intérieur que cela peut
se faire il y a une prévention qui est
effectivement une prévention technique
pratique par exemple comment se fait-il
que les trains soient aussi peu
surveillés il y a d'énormes contrôles
aux aéroports mais n'importe qui peut
rentrer dans un train sans aucun
contrôle et c'est quelque chose qui
m'inquiète
beaucoup mais sinon au niveau de la du
développement de la coopération
internationale également là nous il y a
quelque chose de très important à faire
avec tous ces pays vous avez parlé du
soutien à ces états du Sahel mais je
crois que aussi veulent nous aider nous
avons beaucoup d'alliés dans ces pays et
la prévention au niveau société parce
que le gros problème que nous avons nous
le savons c'est ce problème de ces
jeunes qui sont en déserran qui n'ont
pas de travail qui sont au chômage qui
sont entraînés par des bandes et là
aussi nous avons besoin de travailler à
un niveau plus général je crois beaucoup
à la veille à la
vigilance vous savez je fais partie de
ceux qui ont beaucoup regretté la
suppression du service national qui
permettait justement de repérer ces
jeunes à problèmes et il y a quand même
des outils je pense à la réserve à la
réserve citoyenne qui permet dans ces
banlieux de repérer ses jeunes avant
qu'il ne dérape mon collègue cointa
disait qu'il fallait beaucoup de temps
pour quel que qu'un jeune soit entraîner
vers le djihadisme moi j'en suis pas
persuadé souvent c'est le basculement
qui peut se faire assez vite d'où cette
nécessité de vigilance et de veille et
vous avez raison au niveau bien sûr du
contrediscours qui était essentiel où
nous devons vraiment encourager un
nouveau message vis-à-vis du monde
musulman pour éviter la victimisation de
certains de ces jeunes bon je pourrais
beaucoup continuer mais enfin je m'en
arrête madame gariaum l monsieur longer
merci monsieur le Président jeis
demanderur le ministre de l'Intérieur
j'ai été impressionné par la précision
de ces chift dans les catégories qu' l'a
lui-même défin première question
êtes-vous en mesure de d'assurer un
suivi individuel pour avoir une telle
précision deuxème question les effectifs
évoqués ne sont pas négligeables on
arrive à un peu moins de 1000 avez-vous
une sociologie de de ces effectifs 3è
question sur quels moyens humains du
ministère comptez-vous et sont-ils
suffisants et et 4è question comment
s'articule le travail intérieur et
extérieur des GSE des
séries monsieur
longuer je n'ai plus de demande de
parole
oui monsieur
Lorjou juste un mot pour dire que la
réponse sociétale qui est une réponse
d'ensemble qui demande une politique
interministérielle n'est nullement
contradictoire de l'excellence des
mesures à court terme proposé par le
ministre de
l'Intérieur merci Monsieur Lorjou je me
permettrai d'ajouter une remarque
monsieur le le
ministre vous savez que
le décret qui était prévu dans laalopsie
voté en
2011 pour bloquer les sites Péo
pornographique n'est jamais paru et il
n'est pas paru en raison de l'opposition
des fournisseurs d'accès à
l'Internet donc par rapport au au la à
la proposition que vous que vous avez
énoncé pour bloquer les sites faisant
l'apologie du terrorisme
par assimilation à ceux qui font
l'apologie des crimes contre
l'humanité est-ce que un dispositif
similaire est envisagé oou est-ce qu'il
est possible d'obtenir une
décision plus effective puisque il y a
une loi le décret n'est pas paru par
opposition des fournisseurs d'accès si
nous faisons une nouvelle loi qui
prévoit l'interdiction des sites faisant
l'apologie du terrorisme aurons-nous les
moyens de
l'appliquer est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions mes chers collègues oui
monsieur longuer notre collègue Michel
est souvent mieux inspiré que de
rapprocher les volontaires pour le
combat en syriie des de ceux qui
s'engageaient comme volontaires dans les
Brigades internationales et pour la
raison d'ailleurs juridique suivante
c'est que le gouvernement espagnol était
un gouvernement légal que la France
reconnaissait et l'engagement dans une
armée républicaine n'est pas tout à fait
de la même nature alors il y a des des
droits français qui je crois ne
permettent pas à un français de de
porter les armes d'un pays étranger
encore que nous le fassions avec la
Légion étrangère et que le tertio l'a
toujours fait mais le tertio était
justement contre le gouvernement
républicain deuxième remarque nous
avions un accord militaire avec la
Grande-Bretagne grand la Grande-Bretagne
y en avait un avec nous en
1939 et en 1940 et certes le général de
Gaulle a été condamné à mort par un
tribunal de Vichi mais le le
gouvernement britannique était un
gouvernement légal démocratique et nous
avions des accords militaires donc la
comparaison n'est pas tout à fait la
même même si le président Hollande a
évoqué la perspective d'un soutien aux
opposants à Monsieur el-Assad Bachar
el-Assad il n'y a jamais eu de de de
reconnaissance de la l'autorité
politique que représente les opposants
Bach
assad merci Monsieur Longuet Monsieur
Michel cela ne vous inspire pas de
nouvelles remarques non si je vois bien
oui la remarque c'est qu'il faut
toujours se méfier des termes à histoire
et que les terrorisme d'un jour sont des
héros le lendemain quel que soit leur
but d'ailleurs bien merci Monsieur
Michel bien alors la fin ne justifie pas
les moyens en effet Monsieur
Géard merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il est venu deux
questions qui qui sont surgis à l'issue
de cette
discussion la première question c'est
que les réseaux Internet malheureusement
ne connaissent pas les
frontières et que c'est très difficile
de contrôler ces réseaux c'est un peu
comme le nuage de chernoby il s'arrête
pas aux frontières la deuxième remarque
que je voudrais faire c'est qu'il existe
une institution où personnellement
j'aimerais bien que la France y
participe en tant
qu'observateur c'est la convention de
shanghï qui a pour but justement de
d'unir les efforts pour lutter contre le
terrorisme et certaines des réunions il
y en a une qui va se tenir d'ailleurs
incessemment certaines des réunions de
la convention de shanghï pourrait être
peut-être intéressante pour nous non pas
d' faire partie puisque ça concerne
essentiellement les États-membres de la
CEI mais d'être informé de ce qui se
passe au cours de cette de ces table
rondes de la convention de de
shanghï merci monsieur gellard mes chers
collègues s'il n'y a plus d'intervention
je pense monsieur le ministre que vous
avez pu voir tout l'intérêt que vos
propos suscitz et combien nous sommes
euh euh attaché à travailler
profondément sur ces questions donc je
vous rends la parole monsieur le
ministre bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président beaucoup de questions ont été
euh évoquées par chacune et chacun
d'entre vous et je souhaiterais pouvoir
apporter des réponses qui soient les
plus précises possibles même si je ne
peux pas contenu du nombre de questions
posées prétendre nécessairement à
l'exhativité mais je suis convaincu qu'à
l'occasion des débats parlementaires et
d'autres séances de ce type j'aurai
l'occasion de répondre à tout ce que
j'aurais oublié de
mentionner premier point sur lequel je
voudrais insister c'est sur ce qui a pu
être dit sur l'antisémitisme d'une part
et d'autre part sur la disposition
d'interdiction de sortie du territoire
et les derniers propos tenus par le
sénateur Michel sur les terroristes
d'aujourd'hui susceptibles d'être les
héros de demain et ce que je vais vous
dire là je je souhaite le dire de façon
extrêmement précise et en même temps un
peu solennelle parce ce sont des sujets
d'une grande gravité d'abord les faites
d'antisémitisme et ce qui s'est passé à
Bruxelles le sénateur le comte l'a
rappelé d'autres également est un acte
de violence c'est un crime qui a été
perpétré à l'encontre de ressortir sans
belge parce qu'ils étaient juifs c'est
ça la réalité sont des actes
d'antisémitisme qu'il faut qualifié
comme tel l'antisémitisme
c'est en 2013 au 1er quadrimestre de
2013 163 faits au prier quadrimestre de
2014 en France
211 il y a une
augmentation de 30 % des faits
d'antisémitisme d'une année sur l'autre
c'est une réalité statistique elle a la
froideur des réalités statistiques mais
elle elle dit bien l'état d'esprit d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs qui font fi des
faits de l'histoire dont on connaît la
dimension éminemment tragique au moment
où nous célébrons le 70e anniversaire de
la libération de notre pays fait qui on
conduit des familles entières des femmes
des enfants à partir dans les camps de
la mort parce qu'ils étaient juifs et le
fait que l'on puisse 70 ans après au
moment où nous célébrons la libération
du territoire national
reprocéder à ces actes de haine comme si
rien ne s'était passé et plus odieux que
n'importe quelle autre forme de
violence je veux d'ailleurs donner des
éléments précis sur ces actes
d'antisémitisme 36 % des actions
recessensé port sur des violences ou
voix de fait commis sur des personnes
physiques dont 12
mineur six actions enregistrées l'ont
été en milieu scolaire 14 sur des
synagogues deux sur des cimetières et
les 153 faits de menace enregistrés en
2014 sont pour 50 % des inscription des
tags à caractère raciste antisémite et
haineux 40 % des propos des gestes
menaçants des démonstrations
injurieuse
donc l'antisémitisme existe il est une
forme de haine intolérable au regard de
ce qui s'est passé dans l'histoire qui
mérite une dénonciation ferme
et de
façon extrêmement claire quel que soit
l'origine de ces manifestations
d'antisémitisme quel que soit l'origine
de
l'antisémitisme deè point la disposition
je réponds là au sénateur Michel et à
tous ceux qui sont exprimés également
monsieur le conte sur ce sujet la
disposition
d'interdiction administrative de sortie
du territoire que je propose de prendre
pour les personnes majeures concernerait
tout ressortissant français dont les
déplacements à l'étranger sont
susceptibles de porter atteinte aux
intérêts fondamentaux de l'État ou
d'être liés à des activités terroristes
des crimes de guerre ou des crimes
contre
l'humanité de manière à ce que les
critères d'incrimination soit clair ne
concerne pas n'importe quel type d'acte
de citoyen et par ailleurs ne puisse se
prolonger dans le temps que sous le
contrôle du
juge judiciaire voilà donc je tiens à
préciser cela non mais après au terme
d'une période l'interdiction est
administrative mais sa prolongation dans
le temps pour éviter ce qui était
indiqué ne pourrait se faire que voilà
donc je tiens à préciser cela et par
ailleurs pour être tout à fait
transparent et puis surtout tout à fait
franc dans l'échange républicain que
nous avons moi je ne considérerai jamais
comme les héros de
demain des criminels qui vont dans des
groupes terroristes et reviennent sur le
territoire national pour tuer des
ressortissants dans notre pays parce que
ils ont telle ou telle appartenance
religieuse ou sont attachés à telle ou
telle valeur ces gens-là ne pourront
jamais être des héros ils resteront à
tout jamais des criminels et cela doit
être dit au moment où nous engageons
dans ce combat parce que ce combat ne
peut pas être mené il ne peut pas être
gagné si nous ne mettons pas de l'ordre
dans les principes dans les valeurs et
dans la
hiérarchie des principes et des valeurs
qui nous conduisent à combattre donc
voilà ce que je voulais dire sur ce
point il y a un deuxième
point sur lequel je voudrais
insister qui est très important aussi
parce que je je réponds là à Esther
Benbassa et d'autres orateurs le fait
que je propose de prendre des mesures
répressives il faut les qualifier pour
empêcher les départs pour pour
réprimer
la
l'association de personne via Internet
en vue de commettre des actes
terroristes ou des actes violents
pouvant porter atteinte à l'intégrité
physique ou à la vie de ressortissant
français ne signifie pas que le plan que
nous proposons est un plan exclusivement
répressif qui manquerait de vision
globale le plan que nous proposons est
un plan global et je veux là aussi avoir
la
précision sert pour vous en convaincre
ce plan repose sur cinq
axes le premier axe c'est prévenir et
empêcher les
départs prévenir empêcher les départs
par l'inscription des personnes dont
nous savons par le travail de
renseignement auquel il est procédés
qu'ils sont susceptibles dès lors qu'ils
partirai de s'engager dans des troupes
djihadistes en les inscrivant au fichier
des personnes recherchées au système
d'information
Schengen cela peut faire aussi l'objet
de retrait de passeport
l'opposition à la sortie du territoire
des personnes mineures dès lors que les
parents nous les ont signalé fait une
mesure qui fait également partie du plan
et des entretiens administratifs avec
nos services de personnes sur lesquels
nous avons des interrogation peut
permettre également d'assurer un suivi
le plus fin possible de ressortissants
dont nous pensons qu'à un moment ou un
autre ils peuvent représenter un danger
sans préjudice aucun pour la liberté de
ces personnes deuxièmement nous voulons
démentiler les filières c'est le deuxème
axe ça implique effectivement que nous
prendrons des mesures nous en avons déjà
prises d'ailleurs d'expulsion
d'étrangers sur le territoire national
convaincu d'avoir participé à des
entreprises terroristes ça veut dire le
gel administratif et préventif des
avoirs des filières terroristes ça veut
dire
aussi la déchéance de nationalité dans
des conditions restrictives prévues par
la loi de ressortissants qui peuvent
porter porter atteinte à la sécurité
nationale ça veut dire une action très
forte de prévention en liaison avec
l'administration pénitentière mobilisant
non seulement l'administration
pénitentiaire nos propres services de
renseignement mais aussi les
représentants des cultes musulmans mais
aussi des organismes de formation d'imam
de manière à lutter contre la
radicalisation et la diffusion du
discours radical en milieu carcéral mais
ça peut vouloir dire aussi de
l'accompagne individualisé psychologique
et pas seulement psychologique éducatif
de détenus dont nous pensons qu'ils
peuvent basculer faute de cet
accompagnement donc c'est vraiment un
accompagnement global pluridisciplinaire
qui va mobiliser énormément de moyens et
nous sommes là dans une approche globale
et
préventive ça veut dire également sur le
démantellement des filière la
généralisation du régime juridique de
l'enquête sous pseudonyme la
révalisation périodique de la stratégie
de judiciarisation hiérarchisant les
objectifs ça veut dire faciliter
l'exploitation du renseignement par
l'allongement de la durée de
conservation d'un certain nombre de
données notamment celle qui résulte des
interceptions de sécurité 3è axe
soutenir les familles et les orientés
c'est l'objet du numéro vert euh c'est
l'objet du réseau d'orientation et de
soutien déconcentrés piloté par le
préfet le procureur je m'attarder 2
secondes sur ce point pour bien montrer
que nous sommes dans cette approche
globale
moi je souhaite et c'est l'objet de
l'instruction que j'ai adressé au préfet
qu'autour des préfets des procureurs
dans le casre d'une grande
confidentialité l'éducation nationale
les services des conseils généraux les
services des collectivités locales
puissent agir ensemble ça ne sera pas la
solution à tout le problème mais puisse
agir ensemble lorsqu'il y a des signes
de décrochage ou de risque avant même
que le basculement ne soit intervenu
pour faire en sorte que le basculement
n'intervienne pas et nous sommes là dans
cette approche globale mobilisant tous
les services de l'État et des
collectivités locales avec les
précautions de confidentialité qui doit
s'imposer qui doivent s'imposer entre
les acteurs de ce réseau qui agiront
ensemble et la crise la création d'un
programme de prise en charge
individualisé dans dans les
agglomérations les plus concernées doit
aussi permettre la mobilisation des
forces de sécurité et des élus locaux
dans ce sens 4e axe communiquer
sensibiliser formmer projet expé mental
en vue d'action de contrepropagande
impliquer les autorités religieuses pour
développer un contre disccours
sensibiliser les familles les éducateurs
les services sociaux au signau de la
radicalisation création d'une cellule
nationale interministérielle d'appui et
enfin renforcer la coopération
internationale parce que tous les pays
de l'Union européenne sont confrontés au
même phénomène de départ tous les
services de renseignement sont
confrontés aux mêmes contraintes de
suivi et s'il n'y a pas une coopération
un travail en commun de la
transversalité nous n'y arriverons pas
aussi facilement que nous pourrions y
arriver si nous disons
ensemble donc l'approche globale est
bien notre
préoccupation elle contient cette
approche globale un volet répressif qui
relève plus particulièrement de la
compétence du ministère de l'Intérieur
qui a moins de compétences éducatif que
d'autres ministères même si je l'assume
par conséquent devant vous mais elle
n'est pas exclusive de tout le reste que
nous pouvons faire ensemble et je le dis
parce que je veux vous convaincre de
cette préoccupation d'approche globale
je veux également vous convaincre du
fait
que zéro précaution face à un phénomène
comme celui auquel nous sommes
confrontés c'est 100 % de risque
potentiel mais 100 % de précaution ce
n'est pas le risque zéro et il faut
aussi le dire parce que
euh on peut toujours se trouver
confronté à un moment ou à un autre à un
processus de
dissimulation à une arrivée subite de
quelqu'un qui n'est pas nécessairement
ressortissant de notre pays mais venant
d'un autre pays de l'Union européenne à
l'instar de ce qu'a pu faire nemmouche
en Belgique et qui frapp donc vraiment
je crois que cette formule est
bien emblématique de la difficulté zéro
précaution c'est 100 % de risque mais
100 % de précaution n'est pas le risque
zéro sur les sujets dont nous avons à
connaître et à traiter je voudrais
ensuite
euh apporter quelques éléments en
répondant à chacun rapidement sur les
questions qui ont été évoquées pour si
consiste pour la question qui concerne
la situation humanitaire en Syrie posé
par Monsieur le Comte il y a une
situation humanitaire en Syrie qui peut
mobiliser des jeunes et cetera les
éléments dont nous disposons montrent
qu'un certain nombre de jeunes basculent
dans les groupes djihadistes en raison
d'images diffusées par les groupes
djihadistes eux-mêmes par internet sur
la situation humanitaire en Syrie expité
par ces groupes afin de favoriser le
basculement de ces jeunes c'est
incontestable ça existe mais ce qui doit
être dit aussi c'est que dès lors que
ces jeunes
basculent pour des raisons initialement
humanitaires dans le djihad en Syrie il
s'engage dans des actions qui n'ont rien
à voir avec ce que l'humanité dicte aux
hommes soucieux de faire de
l'humanitaire parce que tous les
témoignages que nous avons et tous les
éléments que nous avons conc ant les
conditions d'engagement de ces jeunes
dans les groupes djihadistes montre que
ce n'est pas l'action humanitaire qu'il
fréquente mais la violence dans sa forme
la plus brutale le crime le meurtre la
décapitation et le reste et que cela
doit être dit parce que cette tromperie
là est consubstantielle à
l'endoctrinement qui conduit ces jeunes
à basculer après que sur internet ils
ont rencontrer des sites des blogs ou
des forums de discussion et j'ai eu
l'occasion avec mes collaborateurs de de
voir un certain nombre de vidéos qui
sont diffusées sur Internet conduisant à
l'endoctrinement pour des raisons
humanitaires d'un certain nombre de ceux
qui basculent nous sommes dans un
véritable phénomène de propagande et
d'endoctrinement de caractère sectaire
avec la part de dissimulation de
manipulation qui s'attache à cette
propagande et qui doit être condamné en
tant que tel parce que c'est une
instrumentalisation
d'une situation humanitaire à des fins
d'endoctrinement de basculement dans la
violence radicale et sans retour de
jeunes qui peuvent effectivement
témoigner un moment ou un autre d'une
fragilité psychologique et cela doit
être dit par ce qui exerc une
responsabilité publique et dénoncé parce
que c'est d'une extrême
gravité pour ce qui concerne les délis
sur
Internet sénateur lete dit la loi ne
sera jamais supérieur à la technique
c'est vrai que la technique utilisée par
Internet peut mettre la loi en situation
d'échec lorsqu'elle veut réguler ce qui
se passe sur internet mais cet espace de
liberté qui est Internet ne peut pas
sous prétexte qu'il est un espace de
liberté et en dépit du Premier
Amendement auquel les Américains se
réfèrent souvent être un espace où tout
est permis y
compris la diffusion de pensées de
propos euh
de haine
euh qui peuvent
conduire des ressortissants de nos pays
à perdre tout
repère moi je n'accepte pas et je pense
que nous sommes nombreux dans cette
salle à être dans cet état d'esprit que
sous prétexte que internet est un espace
de liberté on puisse sans régulation de
cet espace y trouver des tweets y
trouver des blogs y trouver des sites
dans lesquels la haine est le vecteur de
tout la haine antisémite la haine de
l'autre le racisme la violence avec les
photos les vidéos qui s'y
attachent et c'est un combat qu'il faut
mener qu'il faut mener à l'échelle
européenne en lien avec les Américains
pour rappeler les fournisseurs d'accès à
Internet à leur responsabilité
éthique parce que sinon il n'y a plus de
valeur il n'y a plus de principe il n'y
a plus de règles il n'y a plus de limite
tout peut être transgressé et tout ce à
quoi nous croyons et qui nous rassemble
pardelà nos différences dans l'espace
commun qui est la République peut-être
mis à mal enfin vous évoquez la
sécurisation de Schengen et des
frontières de Schengen c'est précisément
le dispositif que nous voulons mettre en
place à travers le
PNR passenger name record qui est
destiné à faire en sorte que nous
puissions aux frontières de l'Union
européenne entre nous échanger des
informations dans le strict respect des
libertés publiques qui nous permettent
ensemble de sécuriser nos aéroports nos
voies de communication et faire en sorte
que nous puissions être protégés de ceux
qui d'évidence présentent un risque pour
la sécurité de nos pays monsieur Colomba
vous avez une formule juste vous dites
le terrorisme n'est pas une
nouveauté c'est vrai que le terrorisme
n'est pas une nouveauté mais la forme
qui prend aujourd'hui est
inédite nous ne sommes pas du tout
confrontés à la même menace que celle
oui mais celle-ci est particulièrement
insidieuse et vous avez raison il y en
aura une autre demain parce qu'elle est
mutante plus que toutes les autres
auparavant
oui mais c'est précisément ce que nous
essayons de faire c'est c'est ce que
vous avez exprimé dans votre question et
la préoccupation du gouvernement et dans
les échanges que je peux avoir avec mes
hmologues européens une préoccupation de
premier plan pourquoi parce que nous
avons en face de nous des acteurs qui
sont dans la dissimulation j'ai été très
frappé là aussi de voir qu'un certain
nombre de sites internet expliqu à
ressortissant qui basculent la manière
dont ils doivent se dissimuler y compris
auprès de leurs parents pour que le
basculement se fasse sans que
l'inquiétude dans les familles ne
commence à
poindre j'ai reçu les familles de jeunes
qui sont partis c'était à la fois
bouleversant et terrifiant et glaçant de
voir une mère dont les deux enfants sont
morts en Syrie m'expliquer queelle avait
vu ses enfants s'engager dans des
mouvements radicaux elle avait vu
apparaître tous les de cette radicalité
quand elle avait manifesté l'inquiétude
de ces signes les enfants l'avaient
rassuré puis les signes avaient disparu
pendant quelques semaines et les enfants
étaient
partis au moment où la mère commençait à
s'apaiser elle a découvert par la suite
que les sites en question qui avaient
convaincu ses enfants de partir étaient
des sites qui comprenaient les
recommandations de dissimulation qui
avait conduit ses enfants à partir
dans l'ignorant
de ce qui se préparait pour les parents
donc on est en face d'une réalité qui
est mouvante mutante manipulatrice
dissimulatrice et nous sommes surtout
face à une réalité qui conduit des
personnes à partir et lorsquelle
reviennent contenu de la violence
extrême je ne dirai pas ici ce qui
porait à notre connaissance concernant
les atrocités qui sont perpétré mais on
ne peut pas rester indemne après les
avoir rencontré ces atrocités sur le
site des opération djihadiste et quand
on revient sur le territoire national le
traumatisme psychologique est tel que
bien des choses peuvent se produire
c'està la raison pour laquelle je je
considère que cette notion de N nous
solitaire n'a pas de sens parce que même
s'ils agissent seuls à un moment ou à un
autre le traumatisme auquel ils ont été
confrontés qui a fait l'objet de
l'organisation de propagande et
d'endoctrinement que j'aiindiiqué lui
n'est pas un acte solitaire donc nous
sommes et et et ses ressortissants bien
entendu qui sont sur notre territoire il
faut en avoir conscience et par
conséquent sans faire peur parce qu'on
ne résiste pas à ces phénomènes sans
garder de la distance et du sang- frroid
il faut dire la vérité sur ce risque il
faut le dire et s'armer pour y faire
face et nous ne sommes pas face à un
phénomène qui ressemble au phénomène que
nous avons pu connaître lorsque des
risques d'attentat existaient pour notre
pays Perm perpétré par des gens qui
venaient d'ailleurs et qui après avoir
commis ses attentats repartaient nous
sommes face à un risque d'une toute
autre nature et qui implique une autre
organisation de nos méthodes de travail
d'autres formes de coopération
européennes et qui implique que nous
ayons conscience de la nature du risque
pour faire en sorte que ce risque soit
combattu de façon efficace sans remettre
en cause les principes de liberté
publique qui sont consubstantiells à la
démocratie et sur lesquels il n'y a pas
de négociation possible bien
entendu je voudrais dire un mot auss en
réponse à Esther ben Bassa monsieur Vial
sur la question de la relation entre la
violence radicale et la
religion ce qui me frappe à mesure que
des profils nous sont présentés c'est
que cette violence elle est engendrée
par une ignorance totale de ce que sont
les
religion ce n'est pas la rencontre
d'imam radicaux dans les mosquées qui
conduit au basculement d'un grand nombre
de ceux qui basculent c'est la violence
radicale et la manipulation sectaire par
inter net qui se trouve majoritairement
à l'origine de ce basculement et c'est
l'ignorance de ce qu'est la religion qui
autorise ce basculement et non pas sa
fréquentation parce que comme vous
l'avez dit très justement monsieur
Quinta l'islam de France est tout le
contraire de cela tout le contraire de
cela et l'islam en général également
c'est une forme de dévoiement de
déviance
d'instrumentalisation qui conduit à ce
basculement pourquoi il devient
terroriste c'est ça pourquoi ils son
sensi et pas psychologique c'est pas que
la psychologie c'est pas quel personne
il y a avant et je réponds à la
question
ou Mouv de jeuness mais madame la
sénatrice
et le sénateur longuer m'a posé la
question de savoir quel était le profil
psychologique et là aussi je veux dire
des choses qui vont peut-être suiter des
interrogations mais je les
assume beaucoup de ceux qui basculent
ont été avant d'être des radicaux des
délinquants ils l'ont
été petits délinquants mais délinquant
petits ou des délinquentss ils ont été
des délinquentss bon et ils basculent à
un moment ou un autre parce que pour
pour plein de raisons d'abord parce que
c'est vrai qu'un certain nombre d'entre
eux peuvent ne pas voir d'issu après que
la délinquence et la résidif les a
enquisté dans une forme de relégation et
d'échec c'est possible certains
également bascule parce que la
fréquentation de ces sites
d'endoctrinement de ces blog de
propagande les conduit à une forme de
niilisme très nouveau où finalement la
mort est presque sacralisée comme une
étape vers une vie ultérieure qui leur
est présenté comme quelque chose
d'absolument nirvanis qu'on regarde
l'existence qu'ils ont c'est donc une
tromperie et une duperie majeure mais
quelques soit la cause quelle que soit
la cause rien ne peut
excuser rien ne peut excuser et rien ne
peut expliquer la forme de violence
radicale et de crime qui est perpétrée
rien et autant nous devons nous attaquer
à tout ce qui peut de façon préventive
empêcher le basculement autant nous
pouvons pas sous prétexte de la
préoccupation préventive rentrer dans
une autre logique qui consisterait dans
l'examen des causes à trouver quelque
excuse que ce soit aux faits qui sont
commis tellement ceuxci sont monstrueux
et nous devons aussi avoir cette clarté
parce que si nous n'avons pas cette
clarté nous nous désarmons face au
phénomène qui doit être condamné de
façon absolue totale et ferme en raison
de la dimension criminelle et
monstrueuse qu'il représente alors pour
pour répondre à Gérard Longuet pourquoi
d'abord la précision
euh
la la précision des chiffres Gérard sur
sur la question que vous me posiez bon
nous nous avons des ordres de grandeur
qu'il faut retenir comme des ordres de
grandeur parce que oui ce sont des
ordres de grandeur ils sont précis dans
leur expression parce qu'ils résulte de
travail qui est fait par nos
propres services et forces de sécurité
ils sont le résultat de l'agrégation de
données qui sont en permanence
actualisée ils correspondent malgré tout
ces chiffres à l'ordre de grandeur réel
du phénomène sur notre pays à la fois
pour ceux qui sont le sur le théâtre des
opérations ceux qui sont sur le
chemin de la Syrie ceux qui sont sur le
chemin du retour et ceux qui sont déjà
rentrés cela mobilise des moyens humains
significatifs qui en Mobilis et ces
moyens humains seront d'ailleurs
davantage encore mobilisés dans le
casadre de la réforme de la direction
générale de la sécurité intérieure
puisque nous avons prévu de procéder à
des recrutement et pour ce qui concerne
le travail intérieur extérieur
c'est-à-dire ministère de l'Intérieur et
autres ministères il y a une approche
interministérielle et nos services
intérieur extérieur travaillent de façon
remarquable ensemble selon des modalités
sur lesquelles je ne veux pas m'attarder
par souci d'efficacité de ce travail
mais en tous les cas ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que les choses fonctionnent
de façon très efficace et absolument
remarquable pour pouvoir permettre à
ceux qui sont en situation de
responsabilité de prendre les décisions
qui doivent être prises
voilà ce que je voulais dire alors une
dernière question a été posée par le
président qui
concerne
la
disposition réglementaire d'application
de de la
lopsie alors pour ce qui concerne le
décret sur la pédopornographie le
travail de rédaction de ce décret se
poursuit dans le casadre d'une
concertation avec les opérateurs vous
savez que une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel avait été prise par
laquelle le Conseil constitutionnel
considérant que cette mesure que nous
proposions de blocage des sites et
d'intervention sur internet était dicté
par des considérations d'ordre public
qui justifiaent qu'on indemnisa les
opérateurs en raison de la mesure
d'ordre public que nous avions prise bon
c'est la raison pour laquelle le décret
n'est pas sorti et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous travaillons à sa sortie et
moi je souhaite que ce décret au terme
du travail interministériel qui a été
engagé sorte de manière à ce que nous
puissions
prendre des dispositions sur les
questions que j'ai évoqué aujourd'hui de
façon rapide je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre je me permettre une une
remarque j'ai un grand respect comme
nous tous pour le Conseil
constitutionnel mais j'avoue ne pas très
bien comprendre pourquoi il faudrait
indemniser des
euh fournisseurs d'accès pour le
préjudice qu'ils subissent du fait qu'il
ne touchent pas d'argent en diffusant
des sites
pédoornographiques c'est une remarque
que je me permets de faire je pense que
vraiment non mais vraiment
euh
vraiment oui mais vraiment il y a là
quelque chose qui mérite réflexion après
tout cette loi a été votée en
2011 ça fait déjà 3 années euh elle
n'est pas appliqué et bien entendu nous
pouvons tout à fait souscrire en tout
cas c'est mon cas aux disposition que
vous envisagez par rapport au sites qui
font la propagande pour le terrorisme
mais avec l'espérance que cela puisse
être appliqué rapidement monsieur le
ministre je voulais au nom de tous nos
collègues vous remercier très
sincèrement pour la précision avec
laquelle vous avez bien voulu répondre à
toutes nos questions pour les
informations que vous nous avez apporté
et je crois pouvoir dire au nom de mes
collègues que vous trouverez au Sénat
des interlocuteurs
particulièrement disponible pour cette
question qui dépasse bien d'autres
questions quant à ces conséquences je
vous remercie monsieur le
ministre voilà pour cette audition de
Bernard casenuve le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui a été auditionné sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme par la
commission des Lois du Sénat une
audition qui s'incère dans un contexte
particulier avec la toute récente
affaire my nemmouche auteur de la tuerie
du musée juif de Bruxelles une affaire
qui a montré certaines failles dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme en France
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site sur
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 16h30 pour une double audition celle
de Michel Sapin et de Christian ert par
la commission des finances du Sénat très
bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaire